thank you very much
of and maybe belatedly I think it's
important to say that you know the nexus
is titude is doing a real important job
here because we're demonstrating the
best tradition of European enlightenment
having a public debate in front of an
audience who will Judah Kate at the end
change its mind or be confirmed it in
its opinion because that is a pillar of
democracy to have a open plural today
which unfortunately is not possible in
some countries that we know did I
mention turkey for example or some other
places Europe is a complex place it had
a huge wars and the European Union or
the European community came together
because people put their finger on their
head and they said do we have to kill
each other every 20 years and how do we
go about stopping that and put it all to
simply well the way we're going to stop
that is to create institutions that are
going to be shock absorbers to conflicts
differences of opinion cushions to
frictions and one need not go back to
Machiavelli the one of the founding
fathers of politics to say politics is
conflict and Natalia it is politics
that's good at its politics politics is
about political parties it's good that
Ukraine has a plurality of use or in my
country Serbia or in all of your
countries that's what democracy is about
difference and i use the world politics
in a different sense i use your word
politics in the Machiavelli in the best
tradition of again the Enlightenment
political parties are there to represent
our views and we vote in political
elections to have our voices heard so
it's about the will of the people and
the will of the people from what I
understand watching and observing
Ukraine is that they want to belong to
this family I come from a country that
no longer exists called Yugoslavia I'm
sure many of you have vacationed there
it is today seven countries we did this
to ourselves the Yugoslavs did this to
our
it was peppered and salted afterward by
everyone but we exposed ourselves
instead of doing what the European Union
does work within the institutions to
find that language and maybe separate
quietly like the Czechs and Slovaks did
we unfortunately didn't there was a
plurality but it used arms to do it and
we want to join the European Union all
of the seven countries because we had a
communist regime an authoritarian regime
we didn't have democracy and the
possibility to express ourselves as
Democrats left as socialist etc people
were able to express themselves as serbs
croats Muslims Albanians etc that was
ethnic politics the Ethne fication of
politics and so the European project
after world war two was one that left
out those who fell under the Soviet yoke
there was an imposition this was not
free will so when 89 happened people
said well we can now finally decide and
what did they decide lo and behold
surprised they wanted to return to
Europe and I beg your pardon the
enlargement has been touted as the
biggest success by no others than many
and most people and leaders in the
united kingdom because it has enhanced
trade it has insta enhanced profits for
companies and one need only take one
example and that is of Poland and
Ukraine who have the same starting point
in nineteen eighty nine of their gdp
Poland is up here and Ukrainians down
here so it shows the positive effects of
it and finally although there's much
more to saying I hope we will the fact
that we for example the Western Balkan
countries and of course every example is
different we have had the promise of
membership turkey nur is unfortunately
example I want to mention so you can
begin a negotiation but the European
Union and any member state including the
nether can stop it in any moment and
Turkey is the best example it's a
process that's been going on but I tell
you as someone who lived under communism
in an authoritarian regime
I have always been for the proactive
bring us in and you could stop us at any
time because the benchmarks are there
all the time and again Serbia is the
best example in the Netherlands God
knows had the arrest of Radovan Karadzic
and Ratko Mladic as a benchmark and we
the citizens of Serbia wanted them in
the hague they are there now Karadzic
was now condemned to 40 years rightly so
and so but at the same time without the
arrest of knowledge and I came here when
the stabilization association agreement
we met with your politicians and with
your NGOs and we said don't stop us at
this point because you are only
reinforcing the conservative nationalist
forces by keeping us out and final word
I think the same applies for Ukraine it
is good that they are in the garden
moving forward and you can stop by there
anyway but you give these people the
hope that with this burden sharing of
democratic reform and structural form
which is extremely hard they can
actually start becoming a more rule of
law democratic efficient condemn what
you say
why didn't you consider yourself
European and then what's your problem
with the EU well Camille is a difficult
concept I consider myself as a fan of
European project I think that the idea
too to make Europe strong and better by
sharing our wealth by home a common
market and by making sure that our faith
defense on how we work together it has
work because it has brought peace
lasting peace to Europe and I think that
was the original idea of the European
now I see people who have hijacked this
project and I try to create the United
States of Europe with a central
government we have people like mr.
Forrester and thick and in our own
country mr. pethel who wrote a book the
United States of Europe who really think
that we can only make Europe a real
democracy if we have a central
government in Brussels if will give up
we give up if we give up national
sovereignty sovereignty if we make sure
that everything is done by majority rule
and if we have a European partners that
has taken away the positions from
national parliaments I'm willing to
retire if that happens because that
might my job will leave with this I have
no function done but I don't think there
is I don't think there is public support
for their industries and the people who
the people who are in favor of this idea
have hijacked this project and I think
that are very dangerous because we
should work on maintenance of the
original project we are about to lose
the United Kingdom we have a crisis in
the south we cannot solve the refugee
problem we have a euro crisis at hand we
should solve our problems first because
we go further on the path of enlargement
before we could make new associations we
should solve our problems otherwise
Europe will fall apart and we have seen
in the formulas lava what happens if a
country falls apart it is a very
dangerous product ok John your
perspective well I wrote a book in 1997
called the undemocratic origins of the
European idea
the fish why do you consider yourself a
European well it's a matter of
geographical and cultural fact i was
born in britain and i live in living so
they are Europeans as well yes of course
ok so then what is the European Union is
not equivalent to Europe very obviously
there are numerous European institutions
as the Council of Europe the OSCE and
others in the European Union as harry
said has taken a departure particularly
after the end of the cold war with the
maastricht treaty and the introduction
of the euro a very strong departure
towards federalism and this federalism
has massively damaged the democratic
credentials of the European Union every
single expert on the European Union
agrees that there is a democratic
deficit that deficit consists in the
fact that European laws are made in
secret in secret in the Council of
Ministers by governments if you boo that
shows you don't know what you're talking
about because because it is it is the
case that European laws are made in the
Council of Ministers by governments
voting in secret if you disagree you can
tell me please which government voted
for which law in the last European
regulation you can't because nobody
knows and that is the democratic deficit
a democratic deficit is aggravated
further any by the attitude which I
referred to earlier in May discussion
with with Ivan where according to which
the superior interest of the European
Union it would be would can in some
cases go against democracy jean-claude
Juncker said it there can be no
Democratic vote he said against European
treaties these are very dangerous ideas
because as soon as you put the overall
so-called overall interest of Europe
above basic democratic accountability
and this is this happens daily in the
European Union because there is no
democratic accountability and it happens
once every five years when a referendum
goes against the European Union in 2005
in this country as I've already said and
in France the European Constitution was
rejected but it was reintroduced by the
back door in the Lisbon Treaty and that
is undemocratic and there's no point
booing or compose saying that I'm not
right
I'm right about this well to make my
point out I'll be simply may be
simplistic you know Brussels this
Brussels bashing is being used like at
other times you know people said you
know Moscow is this thing that controls
everything it's not that Europe doesn't
have problems and we acknowledge that
originally democratic deficit there are
individuals who would like to see it
federal but I think that will never
happen I mean we were talking on the way
here the European Union at base is an
intergovernmental institution because of
European history yes there is shared
sovereignty but again I go back to the
reason for that that was the way to
avoid conflict that's why my country
went down the drain because we were not
part of the Peace Project we wish I had
sovereignty in Yugoslavia you have
shared sovereignty in Yugoslavia it
didn't prevent the super boring
augustness authoritarian commit that you
had said so if we did between the Metro
Republic's John we didn't have democracy
fine that's a different issue but you do
saying it was [ __ ] I'm sorry he said it
would shared sovereignty that was the
key to peace you had shared sovereignty
answer in Yugoslavia and you had war
Conan shared sovereignty John there were
three communist Federation's that fellow
our democracy these unis are not offerin
any Yugoslavs democracy that's the key
not the shared sovereignty thank you yes
but Europe overcame its conflict because
it it put its head to its finger as I
said and said how do we avoid that we do
need to share something well coal and
steel were the weather were the things
by which weapons were made and so if we
agree on how we use cold steel community
with so let me finish let me finish so
the the intergovernmental ism is really
what's there during the day and Europe
is in fact a multi-speed from from the
very big the caveats I talked to a
Swedish diplomat at the beginning of
their negotiation or rather their idea
to join real there's a from a big
European country he was told you will
you Swedes will never join Europe so
this is we've been seeing
and you know the European has an
open-door policy you look at the map and
with where and who belongs to them you
cannot impede it yes their difficulty
because Europe needs to deepen you're
absolutely right we need to strengthen
the institutions but i think that Europe
will muddle through this and I the one
thing that I want to say that I think
we're all aware of but we're not saying
here the reason we are debating all this
is both Europe and the United States as
we see in the electoral process we are
all in a very difficult situation where
the ordinary person is uncertain about
tomorrow about their job if they have
one will I have it because of you know
the way the global economic crisis has
gone there is a fact that parents are
saying for the first time in the United
States but also here our children will
not live better than I and I think the
framework of this uncertainty is
prompting us to ask questions one which
is very good but then there's this what
we call the renal ization we're turning
back on ourselves because you know it's
warm and fuzzy when we're with our own
whoever our own are but that I think as
Roger Cohen today in his new york times
op-ed said you know we are moving into
the 21st century but we must not forget
what happened to us in the 20th century
I just like to say the following I think
that the issues are purposefully being
complicated whereas the question before
the Dutch is very simple I have attended
a business forum on wednesday between
Ukraine and the Netherlands and I spoke
with Dutch businessman and they have
demonstrated a lot more faith and belief
in a better Ukraine than the people
sitting in front of me who have not
invested anything in Ukraine and have
not experienced the new Ukraine and they
certainly do not know that Ukraine the
way it is changing today the way it is
adapting its legislation to European
standards will ensure that when Dutch
businessmen are traveling to Ukraine
they do not have to figure out like in a
foreign land the laws that govern their
relationship their business relationship
how to do business in Ukraine when
students travel when people vacation in
Ukraine they will not be traveling to a
foreign land they will be traveling to a
country that is as European as any of
the 28 EU member states and at the end
of the day the simple question that one
has to ask himself or herself on april
six is the following a country the size
of France with a population three times
that of the Netherlands wanting to
embrace European values and live and be
governed by legislation regulation
administrative and judicial processes
akin to the European standards why would
anybody say no to that well they can
they can
they can adapt another blue bean
soundless tomorrow they don't need a
treaty for that well sir the agreement
it took you you said earlier that that
I've mentioned at the beginning that
there were more changes made in the last
24 months what you did not tell the
crowd was that this agreement had
immediate application of many provisions
of that agreement and those provisions
are forcing the necessary changes that
Ukrainian civil society wants that
Ukrainian civil societies stood under my
down for and I think that those changes
are the changes that the agreement the
the support of the European countries
will transform Ukraine into a purely
democratic European corrupt free country
and that is in the best interest of
everyone including of the Dutch